We're going to get ready to start in just a few minutes if you all will take your seats
please.
Welcome everyone this meeting of the Huntsville City Council is called to order it is Thursday
July 9th 2026 and we are met in the City Council chambers in Huntsville Alabama.
We welcome all the people who have joined us here in the chambers this evening and many who
are joining us virtually online. We will begin our meeting with an indication which will be offered
by Huntsville Police Alabama Public Safety Chaplain Scott Lowry which will be followed
by the Pledge of Allegiance and this evening we have some scouts here in the audience with us
who will be leading that pledge for us. We have from troop 42 Emily Domorowski and Miriam Tidwell
from troop 83 John Domorowski and they will come forward after the invocation. So all who are
willing and able to do so please stand for the invocation and the Pledge of Allegiance.
Let us pray. Father we would be remiss if we didn't pause to thank you
that we're blessed to live in a nation that has just celebrated its 250th anniversary.
I thank you for that. I thank you for the way you've blessed our land the way you have blessed our
community. I pray for your continued blessing upon our community upon our leaders. I pray Lord that
you will grant wisdom that you will guide us that you'll continue to lead that you will continue to
provide. Give us discretion Lord and receptivity Lord to divine leadership
and I pray for your blessings now Lord upon all who are participating this evening in Jesus name.
Amen. Gouts you may come forward.
We appreciate you being here tonight.
Do I like speak into it?
I pledge allegiance to the flag of United States of America and to the Republic for which it stands
one nation under God indivisible with immunity and justice for all.
Thank you Chaplain Lowry. Thank you Scouts. We appreciate you being here today.
Council members you have the agenda before you. We have one item that we would like to take out
of order and that is item 20H which is the declaration of appointment for Ryan Renaud who
did not have any opposition in his school board contest. If all are okay with that
change and are there any other changes to be made?
That change and are there any other changes to be made?
Is there a motion to approve the agenda as presented or as changed? Mr. Kling second.
Second from Mr. Little. All in favor please indicate aye. The motion carries and we will
take that out of order and we'll hear that after the presentation of the resolution at 6C.
Council members you have the minutes of the regular meeting of the city council held on
June 25, 2026. Are there any changes or additions to the minutes? Seeing none the minutes will be
accepted as approved as presented. Mayor Battle has a presentation. 5A is a presentation recognizing
that Huntsville salutes America's 250th committee and its partners for their outstanding work in
organizing a year-long celebration of the nation's founding. Mayor Battle. Thank you Madam President.
If I could ask Sally Warden to come up with all of her merry crew who helped put on the 250th
celebration. To each of you we want to say thank you. Y'all did a wonderful job although you didn't
handle the weather very well. It was hot out there very hot but it was just it was a great day and
Sally please tell us about some of the efforts that went on and I have certificates for each
of you to say thank you for doing this and being part of the city of Huntsville and part of our
I guess we would call it our merry crew who made sure that we celebrated this country's 250th
anniversary in the right way. Thank you mayor very much for having us here today. Sorry guys I have
to have a cheat sheet. I wasn't sure what the mayor was and wasn't going to say so I have my
cheat sheet here. Come on guys keep on coming keep on coming it's a big it's a big crowd we got to
I'll get in the picture. Do you want me to start here and introduce first of all mayor I would
like to thank you for having the faith in us. To put on this big show about a year ago guys the
mayor and John Hamilton came to me and asked if I would do this and I said sure as long as I have
a big crew to do it with and this is only a portion of the crew but it is a lot of the crew here and
I thank you for that. Real quick if you don't mind I'm going to run through and introduce some
of the 250th as well as a few others. I'm going to go fast guys I can talk fast. Donna Castellano
with Historic Huntsville Foundation and Harrison Brothers. Jennifer Moore wave guys when I call
your name. Jennifer Moore with the CVB. Claire Ayo from the Chamber of Commerce. William Hampton
Huntsville Revisited. Caressa Acosta Lee from UAH. Kate Monroe from the Public Library as well as
the Hunt Spring chapter of the DAR. Veronica Henderson Alabama A&M. Erin Owen from the City
Communications Department. Dave DeLisser where's Dave he's probably still coming in on his crutches
he is coming though and Kent Ballard from Parks and Rec. That was those are the members up here
of our committee. We also have some folks up here that were instrumental in the parade as well as
Ron Poteet downtown Huntsville Inc. Tremendous partner we couldn't have done it without them.
Henry Thornton from Metta who Henry financed it. That is the other thing the mayor said here
Sally and company throw this party but guess what you have to go raise the money first to do it so
thankfully Metta stepped up and took that challenge and did that. Henry would you like to say a word?
Absolutely if that's all right I promise I'll go very fast. The sponsor's main job is to put money
in the accounts of the people who know how to do the real work and that's the committee
right here and so can we give a round of applause to everyone on the committee.
I'll close with this very briefly. At Metta you know we love upholding our commitment to be good
neighbors in the communities where we have a data center and lots of communities had you know a
similar event to this some sort of America 250 event and Metta was involved in a few of them in
our communities around the country. We found as we checked on this on Monday many people you know
underestimated the interest in their events and were a little overwhelmed. Some other cities
overestimated the interest and didn't have the right crowds. This group right here who did all
the work nailed the exact level of interest in the community. It was a very very hunts for moment
and you should be very proud Sally and everyone else who worked on this. Thank you Henry. One of
the things that is one of those things that just spontaneously happened was Claire actually was at
a meeting at WHNT and they said what's going on for the 250th and WHNT stepped up and broadcast
live the parade which caused Kent Ballard who was a creative genius guru of the parade to step up
and kick it up a whole notch but we have here tonight three of the key players from WHNT.
Olivia Pennington who's the station VP general manager wave guys. Greg Baldwin the news director
and Tracy Holsey the community project director. It was all hands on deck guys. There were
several meetings where we went to that there were 20 to 30 folks from WHNT there and we're so thankful
that you were there and were able to capture all of that. Real quick I need to mention two people
that are not here tonight. One is Natasha Parker. She was the chair of the subcommittee that oversaw
the July 4th. Unfortunately she was out of town, could not be here. The second was Carla Palacios
from DHI and we could not have done this without the help of downtown Huntsville Inc. Carla is the
one that knows where every single thing is in that park and got it all taken care of. So she was as
well as serving all the money ran through DHI as well so she's paying all the bills still.
One of the things early on mayor that I told the mayor I said you know we've got to have the
city's help in this and he gave me a pinky promise literally you know pinky promise with your finger
that said yes the city will be behind you and I cannot thank the city departments enough. We have
one of them up here with us right now Charles Martin giveaways. He is over public transit. He's
one of the ones when Philadelphia was canceling their parade, Washington DC canceled their parade
and I was like oh no we're not canceling our parade. We are not canceling that parade. The
mayor wants a parade. That is what one of the things the mayor said we had to have a parade,
we had to have music and we had to have fireworks so we did just that but Charles is just a great
example of on the fly. He did tremendous work getting our parade goers cooled down quickly.
And that is why we didn't even think twice about canceling our parade because we had great backup
from folks like him in the city as well as the Huntsville Fire Department that we knew were there
and were worried about it even though Kent had been I mean back last November Kent was saying
it's going to be hot we got to plan this right and they did so anyway I thank all of you guys
from the bottom of my heart. I'm eternally grateful to you and all the city departments
all the way from the basement of the print shop who's probably going to be glad not to see me
anymore all the way up to the seventh floor and communications and Erin Owen Erin well okay there
she is. Her job's not over yet because our website is up and going and will continue up and going all
the way through. There are many activities still going on and Erin's going to be the one that's
going to be keeping all those up and going. I have to tell you a funny story one story mayor just one
story about this and parks and recreation was all hands on deck. I said that from the get-go parks
and rec I don't know if there was a single parks and rec employee that wasn't working
all day Friday and all day Saturday and that goes down all the way to their department head
James Gossett who I know he's here somewhere he's not in this room but I know he's probably listening
to me. Eight o'clock fourth of July I'm out there lugging being the music officer out there lugging
and Carla lugging boxes and getting things set up and there's James Gossett and James has one job
but it is a very important job. It is to get I don't know if y'all weren't there while the fireworks
were going off the Huntsville concert band played it was amazing live music from our very own folks
but they had 71 musicians and they had this seating chart that was very detailed about where
the trombones went and where the percussion went. James was out there at eight o'clock
hand setting every single one of those chairs so at 10 o'clock that night when I was going through
the park and the concert band was breaking down and I went to their president and said
how was that how was your seating chart how were those 71 chairs were they good?
She said it was perfection so we know he can do the grunt work if he has to and we also know he
can follow a seating chart really well so anyway mayor we do have one thing for you
oops where'd it go okay and you have to open it now but this because you were pretty insistent
on a parade the parade folks made sure that we got a really good picture of you in the fire truck
riding sweating up no we we sort of we sort of you know did all that photoshop stuff so you look
wonderful with your hair blowing in the breeze but it is a picture that you can hang is that not
great does that not capture the moment that does yep so that's right which by
by the way the fire department built special steps to get the grand marshals were the mayor
former mayor steve headinger and former mayor loretta spencer they built these like five or
six steps that went up and down and when i got i was at the when the the first uh their grand
marshals pulled in and um they whipped those steps up down they came it was it was a sight to see
mayor so we wanted you to have that and again i just want you to know it's not over yet but i'm
not going to bother any more of your departments probably except for aaron um to keep it going on
through the end of 2026 because we still have many community organizations out there that are willing
and want to keep promoting uh the 250th and we're very proud um and i think also um one thing it
hasn't come out ron and i know we're we're working on trying to get a really good estimate it's
really hard to get a very good estimate of how many people were there uh but first scrub
well the mayor's count well you know what mayor's off a little bit a little bit more mayor
we can we can with all all uh conservatively say there were at least over 15 000 people there
by the end of the night um and we don't
And I just like to thank all the citizens that came out that shared their joy and and and patriotic
spirit and spent it with all of us out there sweating in the park so thank you guys very very
much all right now i have one thing to ask the whole committee if you would raise your hand
and repeat after me i am looking forward to to 300 years of this country
and i promise to help with this parade when we have the 300th anniversary
great job thank you thank you so much and thank you for all your work thank you thank you sally
thanks to your crew pictures
matt you're in back back row guy always
that's been in the back row since he was in eighth grade yeah
just always i got you
everybody
thank you
thank you all again for exceptional work and i'm sure mr cling would like me to point out that
while the rest of us rode in the parade he walked the parade route so we're proud of him too
we will move on to a couple of special recognitions from the council
6a is a resolution honoring the exceptional life and legacy of craig sumner a beloved member of
the huntsville community the chair moves for approval second second for mr little all in
favor aye any opposed motion carries i have the honor of making this presentation if the sumner
family would come forward please
so
it's really an honor to read for you a little bit of the history of a man i had an opportunity to
know just working in his neighborhood i didn't know any of this so this was a great revelation
to me and i'm so grateful we can make the community aware of all craig contributed
whereas the city council and the mayor of the city of huntsville alabama wish to honor the
exceptional life and legacy of craig sumner a distinguished figure in the space industry
whose national and local involvement has significantly impacted huntsville and
surrounding areas craig's distinguished career in the space industry began in 1969 as a college
intern with the apollo program working on the design and build of the lunar roving vehicle
craig served in the vietnam war in the united states air force eventually flying c130s
before being honorably discharged in 1976 as a captain he returned to huntsville and nasa working
on other pieces of the space shuttle program before retiring from nasa in 1997 as deputy
project manager for the space shuttle external tank after nasa he worked for the united space
alliance and was the chief engineer of space shuttle propulsion when he retired along with
the space shuttle program in 2011 after his retirement he was asked to work for boeing as
a subject matter expert on the thermal protection system for the core stages of sls artemis and
retired for good in 2024 in addition to his tremendous career in the space industry craig
left a positive impact in the huntsville community including his work with equestrian special olympics
events for 25 years and most recently serving as board chair for first stop he also volunteered
his time and knowledge with the u.s space and rocket center as a docent and i knew him as an
active neighborhood watch member of his south huntsville neighborhood in addition to his nasa
career faithful service to his country and remarkable volunteerism craig was a devoted
husband to his supportive wife linda a 52 years and loving father to two children aaron and carrie
and grandfather to three grandchildren savannah pippa and autumn now therefore be it resolved
that the city council and the mayor of the city of huntsville alabama do hereby recognize and
celebrate the extraordinary life service and legacy of cred craig edmund sumner whose remarkable
contributions to the advancement of space exploration and his unwavering commitment to
the betterment of the huntsville community have left an enduring impact may his dedication to his
profession country and family serve as an inspiration to all ensuring he will be remembered with great
respect gratitude and admiration by the residents of huntsville for generations to come and linda i
will present this resolution to you and i believe aaron's going to say some words
thank you very much first off you you covered 100 of what i was going to say
dad did have a big heart his legacy wasn't just in his accomplishments at work
but in the lives that he touched around huntsville
he inspired many through his acts of kindness his passion his dedication to making a difference
and so thank you again to the city of huntsville and for honoring my dad it's a beautiful tribute
to to the man i knew and and we really appreciate it thank you for sharing him with us thank you
thank you again
thank you
so
is a resolution honoring the north alabama railroad museum on the occasion of its 60th
anniversary is there a motion to approve some of the motion from miss watkins second from
mr little all in favor please indicate i oppose the motion carries miss watkins would you like
to make this presentation
good evening everyone can i get the members of the north alabama rail to come up please
so whereas the city council mayor of huntsville alabama recognized north alabama railroad museum
as a treasured historical and educational institution that has preserved and promoted
the rich rail heritage of north alabama for six decades whereas the north alabama rail museum was
founded in july 1966 in tuscumbia alabama by dedicated volunteers committed to preserving
railroad history whereas the museum relocated his home whereas currently located six nine four
chase road in huntsville during the 1980s whereas throughout the purchase of five miles of abandoned
railway right of way and the successful restoration and reconstruction of that rail line the north
alabama railroad museum created a unique opportunity for residents and visitors to experience
authentic history train excursions throughout the year whereas the museum serves as an important
educational resource by hosting annual field trips that teach young people about rail history rail
safety and the significance of the railroad whereas the north alabama railroad museum preserves and
displays an impressive collection of historic railroad equipment including a railway post office
a military hospital car that served during the korean war a baldwin locomotive a 1949 pullman
sleeper coach and a 1945 locomotive originally built for the united states army providing the
public with a tangible connection to our nation's transportation and military history
whereas for 60 years the north alabama railroad museum has enriched the cultural life of the
huntsville community through the dedication of its volunteers the preservation of historical
artifacts and its commitment to education and heritage now let it be resolved that the city
council and mayor of huntsville do hereby recognize the north alabama railroad museum
on as it celebrates its 60th anniversary and express sincere appreciation for its long-standing
commitment to preserving railroad history educating future generations and enhancing the culture and
historical heritage of the huntsville community and the state of alabama you get him a hand clap
and i will let the president mr hillbill gartner hill gartner right i'll let him say a few words
on behalf of the entire membership thank you for this great honor
since 1986 we've been at our current location the budding north and east of alabama a and
m on chase road this enables huntsville's citizens to be able to ride in a historic train without
having to leave our city and go up to chattanooga in addition they'll be able to see the very
historic trains that were mentioned in the resolution and historic is no exaggeration
our youngest excursion car is 77 years old and the oldest is 102 if anyone is interested our next
excursions will be the 25th of this month and the 1st of august although i personally know that we
have had visitors from over 20 different countries come see us within the last eight years including
wales and mainland china just in the last 60 days we do ask and are grateful for the support
of our citizens as over 90 of our budget comes from coming to people coming and riding on our
trains during excursions and again thank you so much for this recognition
thank you for sharing that presentation miss watkins we will now move on to 6c 6c is a resolution
recognizing louise garman's listen to this 160th 106th i promoted you 106 it's still impressive
106th birthday and celebrating her extraordinary life of civil service accomplishment and adventure
is there a motion to approve motion to mr cling second from miss watkins all in favor please
indicate i oppose the motion carries and mr cling would you like to present this resolution to miss
garman who is 106 years young it would be my honor it is still my honor i come i will come to you
madam president i'd like to read uh this resolution that was just unanimously passed by the city
council and louise let me tell you all of the good words that we are saying about you and your
family they will go into the permanent record of huntsville city government thank you so so that
way when we have those future uh 300 year uh parade workers uh coming down to city hall they
can look at the minutes and they'll be able to read about their great great great grandmother
whereas the city council and the mayor of huntsville alabama wish to extend a heartfelt
106 birthday to louise garman for an outstanding citizen whose life was marked by civil service
accomplishment and adventure louise uh was married to her late husband robert garman
though their honeymoon was cut short when just three days after their wedding he departed to
serve in world war two during this challenging time for our nation louise supported the war effort
by working in the payroll office at mayo clinic an organization that played a significant role
in assisting service manner members and caring for returning veterans whereas after robert's
return from the war they began a new chapter together growing their family and creating a
lifetime of memories they owned several airstream trailers they traveled extensively throughout the
united states achieving what may only many only dream about by visiting every state they were
also active members in the shrineers an organization closely affiliated with the daughters of the nile
where louise rose through the ranks and was elected queen of the nile guiding members and
overseeing activities ceremonies and philanthropic activities sadly in 2003 robert garman passed away
leaving behind an esteemed legacy and a beautiful growing family whereas in 2005 louise moved to
huntsville alabama where she began a new chapter in her life and continued to embrace life's
adventures she attended the adult space camp at the u.s space and rocket center and she became
active in the newcomers club of huntsville establishing many meaningful connections and
deepening her roots through the community whereas louise is the proud mother of two loving children
karen and diana and grandmother of five grandchildren and great grandmother to several
great grandchildren in her free time she enjoys crossword puzzles and playing cards now therefore
be it resolved that the city council the mayor of huntsville alabama hereby congratulate louise
Garman on the celebration of her 106th birthday a milestone that reflects a life filled with stories
and many loved ones and a great remarkable spirit for living life to the fullest thank you very much
i'm going to give you a chance to have the final word you can say make whatever comments you'd like
if you'd like to introduce your family you're welcome to do so yes i'm very happy that my family
is here sitting on my right is diana karen measles her grandson michael measles my son-in-law
mike measles and my great granddaughter lena and michael my grandson's wife
what was that bianca i'm sorry hon i get a little confused i'm so happy to be here tonight
it's been a long journey and a present one all along the way i have so many memories
and i'm just so happy to be here tonight and to share my good fortune with all you people
thank you so much
thank you and here's the reservoir yeah
okay oh okay we'll get our picture okay thank you we are grateful that we could be part of your
journey tonight miss garman many more
thank you um that concludes our uh resolutions and now we will take item 20h
out of order 20h is a resolution to declare ryan rinard to be elected to the board of education
district four of the city of huntsville due to single cat due to single candidacy pursuant to
code the code of alabama 1975 section 11-46-26 motion to approve mr meredith i've just been
asked to six motion to approve mr meredith i've made the motion mr cling has the second
miss miss edwards thank you council mayor battle shandrika edwards city clerk you all received an
official written statement today letting you know there was only one individual mr ryan rinard
to declare candidacy for board of education district four and pursuant to alabama code section
11-46-26 we are due to issue him a certificate of election for a term that will commence on
november 2nd 2026 and he is here tonight with his family mr rinard would you like to say a few words
come to the podium there yeah should we have a recount no i don't think so
dr robinson council members thank you all uh appreciate the vote of confidence um we're
going to chalk this up as 100 turnout and 100 support um despite the state statute i i do want
to take this opportunity miss edwards y'all have a treasure and a gem in shandrika uh we talked at
length during the qualifying window but the work she's doing as city clerk is phenomenal and
certainly remarkable so i want to say thank you miss edwards um and i'll just briefly because
i know we like to stick to business and decorum and i'll thank you all for giving
my two and a half year old daughter a great exercise in decorum tonight but i do just want
to thank you all for your continued leadership and collaboration the progress and momentum
that huntsville city schools is experiencing right now is not without all of your support your
collaboration as a former colleague with miss watkins and two other former board members with
councilman cling and councilwoman robinson i appreciate all of your support and collaboration
over the years between revenue share agreements with an ssut and your collaboration on tiff
districts i'm really proud and excited to live in a community that doesn't just highlight the
importance of great public education but collaborates with us and invests in those opportunities so
thank you all for tonight and thank you for your continued support thank you sir congratulations
don't go far you have to get your election you can bring your family of our communication
department would like to take a picture
i just i just don't remember this happening for me and i won three elections
never got invited down here never never got invited never got recognized at the record show
councilman wakens we're gonna make sure if this opportunity comes again we're gonna treat you
the same way while we get ready for the picture mr little inform me we have not yet had the vote
we have had the discussion all in favor please indicate aye any opposed okay now it's efficient
madam chairman i'd just like to say that school board member ronald has been a great person to
work with done a lot of great things for all of the different schools within the district and i
commend him on his good work that's not what you say at breakfast
we we congratulate you running unopposed really is the best way to run
thank you all for for joining us and best wishes to you we now have the pleasure of receiving a
presentation from the huntsville police citizens advisory council their charter
requires them to give a yearly presentation and so joining us tonight we have the board chair
becky schmidt and i believe she's joined by some colleagues and we will let you give that
presentation and introduce your colleagues all right good evening mayor council and we also
have chief giles here with us tonight i'd like to introduce some of our members who are able to
come tonight dan odom is our vice chair ryan is our ryan o'connor's our secretary and missy hanks
is been a member of hpcac for several years we appreciate them being here the mission of the
hpcac is to strengthen the relationship between hpd and the community through transparency
communication and trust this year i believe we've made meaningful progress towards that goal
hpcac remains engaged with chief giles and command staff by providing citizen perspectives on
department initiatives including recruitment and hiring we've been especially supportive of
the department's recent recruitment efforts and it's been great to see the early hires in the
precincts that seems to be going really well community engagement remains our top priority
we've hosted three public meetings this year the first covered the internal affairs process
the second was a community listening session and the third was about protecting seniors from elder
abuse and fraud while the internal affairs meeting was very well attended the other two had much
lower participation than we hoped we do view this as an opportunity though to continually improve
how we engage with the community throughout the year council members have completed their
write-alongs we have all met our annual training requirements we have reviewed the department's
annual report we have reviewed quarterly internal affairs complaint summaries and we stand ready to
serve on incident review boards when we're called upon i also want to recognize our new members who
you've all appointed who have brought professional expertise and really strengthened our discussions
we're proud to celebrate three of our members for graduating from the citizens police academy
this year that's a huge time commitment we really appreciate them making the time to do that one of
the highlights of this year was a new initiative we recognized officer thomas massey as the
inaugural hpcac officer of the year award and his his background he was perfect at talking about
being a bridge between the community and the police the work he does every day exemplified that
looking ahead one of our biggest priorities is to continue to seek meaningful civic engagement
we know that our work is strongest when we're hearing directly from the citizens and we're
committed to creating more opportunities for meaningful dialogue we've also improved how
residents can communicate with us we discovered a very outdated old city email address and thanks
to lindsay smith and captain clarty we've been able to update our website so our new hpcac email
address is hpcac connect at gmail.com and we encourage anyone with questions concerns or ideas
for future meetings we would love to hear from them before i close i would just like to say thank
you to chief and his leadership and his confidence in the hpcac he is such a blessing to our community
captain clarty he oversees hpcac from the hpd side and lindsay smith from the communications team
and the command staff has been wonderful we appreciate their outstanding partnership
and i also want to thank my fellow hpcac council members for their commitment this is a very unique
volunteer opportunity and it's a pleasure to serve with them and finally want to thank all of you
for your continued support and belief in this program while citizens advisory councils are not
uncommon i recently had the opportunity to speak with leaders from across the country at the all
america cities conference and other chiefs that i spoke to other mayors they were genuinely
impressed with the transparency that our department and the hpcac have that's something that our
community should be very proud of and lastly want to thank all the officers and professional staff
for their service every day it is just incredible every single ride along to get to see the work they
do we look forward to continuing to build on our accomplishments this year to strengthen the
partnership between the police department and the citizens of huntsville and i'm happy to take any
questions thank you miss schmidt council members do you have any questions for miss schmidt miss
watkins how you doing miss smith good how are you good so i just have a few questions yes
um our community how are your community meetings being are they well attended
honestly it depends on the topic if we have a timely topic like internal affairs process that
was well attended because it was something that the community was interested and engaged in when
we have something that's a little more general like a listening session where we we want community
members to come share their experiences with us that's a little harder to get attendance so
we're looking for ways we can make civic engagement fun again by you know maybe going to them and
meeting them where they are versus having these meetings where they come to us is it a marketing
concern is it something that communications department can work on with you to get the
message out we actually met with them a couple weeks ago and had a really productive meeting
and they're doing everything to to market like they would any other parks and rec event
what we need to do a better job of as a council is communicating who we are because we do have a lot
of new people here and we have a lot of people who may not have heard of hpcac and so i think
through that their help with that too that will help drive attendance to our meetings okay my next
question is how does your council measure whether community trust with law enforcement is improving
who that's a good question we don't necessarily have any statistical measurements for that
what we do is review the quarterly internal affairs reports and so you get a good idea as to what
what is the community concerned about what kind of experiences are they having with police
and so through that we might get a glimpse into those relations but we don't necessarily have any
statistical things and that is something that we we'd like to do we talked about putting out a
survey but i had to get that email fixed first so that's that's a great suggestion i think that
would be important because that'll give you a measurement of how well you know the council is
receiving information or how well we're doing in the police department not to say that they're not
doing a great job or a bad job just saying that would be a great measurement yes my next question
is do you have any reoccurring concerns brought to you from the residents or from community members
i hear most frequently that you know just general oh an hpd officer didn't use his blinker or
something like that we have some community members who participate regularly and and share their
concerns um i wouldn't necessarily say we see any trends we just don't have enough people engaging
enough to to really say that um on the flip side i would say the hpd has worked really hard this
year to change how they're presenting us our internal affairs reports so that we can better
see trends within that information on what's going on within the department okay um when i
have town halls um you're always welcome to come thank you i can always put you on the agenda
if you want to attend my town house please let me know i would love for you to come and
be able to engage and communicate with the public yes absolutely i would like you for the job that
all of you are doing thank you i think that's a great suggestion perhaps all of us in our town
town halls could have someone from hpcac come and report on the role of the hpcac and how to
communicate with you great suggestion mr mary thank you um i would suggest reaching out and
working with the community watch organizations and the cro's i think that'll give you a much
better indication of how the public looks at the police force rather than internal affairs documents
which to my understanding come with complaints so all you're getting are complaints from citizens
that for whatever reason feel affronted by the police force as opposed to those that are not
being arrested and therefore come at it from a completely different perspective and with
community watch it is about protecting the neighborhood so i think you're going to get a
better input from those folks than internal affairs that's a great great suggestion we also
the um hpd has started doing a survey when you interact with them they give you a card and
you can fill out we've seen early results of those i think they've only been doing it for
about a year those have been very very positive but of course you only get that that code if you've
interacted with the police so want to make sure that we're having opportunities for people to
give input who maybe didn't have a direct interaction any other comments thank you all
again for your service i know it is more than maybe you had bargained for and we appreciate
your continued um commitment to do this thank you all for your support and would be happy to
come to any of y'all's meetings too thank you uh we council members we will now move on with the
business of the council this evening we have no matters with outside legal representation but
we do have a couple of public hearings 9a is a public hearing in order to hear consider an act
upon all objections and protests if any for removal of a public nuisance at 6026 lancoya
drive northwest huntsville alabama and consideration of a resolution ordering abatement
of a nuisance located at the same property mr erwin yes mayor battle council members from
scott erwin community development department this public hearing is in reference to the property
located at 6026 lancoya drive northwest the property was in violation of the state public
nuisance act regarding junk community development issued a notice to the property owner interested
parties and the property remains in violation community development is seeking your authorization
to abate this junk public nuisance the condition of the property is before you on the video screen
including photos when the property was initially determined to be a nuisance last month or in may
and photos as of yesterday property owners as identified by the tax assessment records
were notified of the time and place where any objections may be heard involving the abatement
of this public nuisance council member property owners and his family have made substantial
improvement on removing this junk nuisance however the conditions of a nuisance still do exist
upon your approval of this resolution we will continue to work with the property owner to allow
them the opportunity to complete the cleanup however failure to do so uh failure to remove
all the junk and debris in a reasonable time will result in the same moving forward with our standard
abatement process the public hearing on item 9a is now open is there anyone wishing to comment
on this item please come forward to the microphone right here and if you'll give us your name
and address for the record please
hello hello my name is trent griffin 3607 nathalie avenue thank you for joining us the property
the property at 6026 belongs to my brother nathaniel griffin and i first want to uh say thank you for
the opportunity to address the council people do not change except for extreme situations
in striking rock bottom is one of them a desire to change is another and boundaries are another
gene has we call him gene has faced all of those recently and it is part of the reason he is not
here privately gene has expressed remorse about the way he maintained his property and uh this
is an opportunity to publicly uh express remorse to his neighbors for the conditions that he has
subjected them to uh we have been working since we got the notification to to clean up you saw some
of the new pictures but we still have some that remain uh to be done i've talked with mr webster
mr erwin and we will work diligently to resolve what is left to be done thank you sir we appreciate
your comments all right is there anyone else who wishes to comment hearing hearing none the the
public hearing is now closed is there a motion to motion for mr little second by the chair oh
second by miss watkins is there any discussion miss watkins yes um mr um we call him gene as well
but mr griffin reached out to me last week and he did express remorse for how his property looked
but he is unable to do anything so he's depending on the kindness of his brother and other
of his friends that are helping getting the property cleared off but he he did express how
sorry he was and that he will get it cleaned off so i had talked to mr erwin and mr erwin has been
talking with his brother as well so we we hopeful that it'll get cleared off soon wonder and thank
you for working with them scott and um sure last night webster thank you and mr erwin how long do
we have so 30 days normally the time that's why i communicated to mr riffin so uh we'll work with
them based on the needs that they have made substantial improvements uh the cars and some
of the debris it is a small amount remaining all right very good council members any other comments
all those in favor please indicate aye any opposed motion carries thank you we'll move on to 9b 9b
is a public hearing on authorizing the demolition of an unsafe building constituting a public
nuisance located at 3208 10th avenue southwest huntsville albama consideration of resolution
pertaining to the same mr erwin this resolution will authorize the demolition of an unsafe building
constituting a public nuisance located at 3208 10th avenue the owners and interested parties were
notified of the public news for the public hearing by certified mail and first class mail
the industry parties may be present to present any objections we had photographs of the property
for review on the screen the property was initially inspected by an independent contractor
to determine the house was not structurally feasible for repair it scaled at 83 percent loss
the independent assessment noted extensive damage to the siding roofing walls floors and the ceiling
the property has been declared an unsafe structure for nine years with no permits or repairs or
demolition permits requested and official notice was sent by certified and first class mail
requesting the demolition or removal of the structure by june the 22nd 2026 no action was
taken by the owners or interested parties and so we're now requesting authorization to abate this
public nuisance the public hearing on item 9b is now open is there anyone wishing to comment on this
item anyone wishing to comment seeing none the public hearing is now closed is there a motion
a motion from mr little second by mr cling council members do you have any comments or questions
seeing none all in favor please indicate aye any opposed motion carries thank you council members
thank you mr erwin thank you mr erwin and mr webster we appreciate your good work
we have several hearings to be set 10a is a resolution to declare a public nuisance located
at 2117 ridgeway street southwest hansfield albam and to set a date for when objections will be
heard is there a motion to set the hearing for july 23rd motion for mr cling second from mr
little all in favor please indicate opposed motion carries 10b is a resolution to set a public
hearing on the zoning of 24.67 acres of land lying in the north side of university drive east of
providence main street highway business c4 district and introduction of an ordinance pertaining to the
same is there a motion to set the hearing for august 27 motion for mr little second from
miss watkins all in favor please indicate you oppose the motion carries 10c is a resolution
to set a public hearing on the zoning of 1.98 acres of land lying on the north side of capsia
road west of walteriana highway to neighborhood business c1 district and introduction of an
ordinance pertaining the same as their motion to set the hearing for august 27 motion for mr
little second from miss watkins all in favor please indicate aye and he posed the motion carries
this brings us now to agenda related comments we have one person signed up is mr howard ross still
here then we will move forward to council member comments and we will begin or i'm sorry mayor's
comments we will uh we will turn the time over to mayor battle uh thank you madam president council
um about spending most of my time uh on the on the fourth of july uh celebration but we do want
to thank each and every person who came out and enjoyed and helped celebrate and especially those
who helped organize the celebration uh today we just just came from uh reception for general
lieutenant general john rafferty uh who is our new space and missile defense command uh commander
he um he's new to the community and uh it was great getting to meet him and have a conversation
with him and uh get him to and uh he was able to meet meet much of our community there and also
yesterday we had the grand opening of the keller williams out in hampton cove uh they must have
you know 150 agents out there uh you could have bought a house real quick if you'd wanted to
uh but it was it was a great day and um and a lot of fun watching uh companies grow and grow with
our city uh so uh that was great and uh madam president that's all i have thank you mayor
battle we'll move on to council member comments and we will hear first from council member bill
cling well thank you madam president i'm going to be very brief uh i appreciate the good work
that scott erwin and others have done with a couple issues that we just dealt with uh somewhere
in the horizon i think we're going to have serenity apartment building coming to us and
i want to just encourage the legal department to let that move through as quickly as possible
that has been a long-standing blight in that neighborhood area over there and it has a history
that uh i think it's been pretty obvious so i just want to kind of wave a flag to cheer on
our departments taking everything through the courts and going through the legal process but
please bring it to the council for whatever action is needed at the appropriate time and
again let me congratulate everybody for what i think was a phenomenally great uh fourth of july
celebration uh we had thousands and thousands of people that came out and hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of people that had been working and are still continue to work on on this very special
celebration that we have in our country and it's been a great event but please take a moment just
to kind of think what the fourth of july is all about what it means and the freedoms that we have
we are blessed with so many great things in this country we have challenges of course but again i
like to look at a glass of water as being half full not half empty and we have so many great
things to celebrate so thank you for everyone who participated thus far at our celebrations that
we've had and it looks like there's still some more great events are going to be coming up
over the upcoming months thank you madam president thank you mr cling we'll hear from council member
david little thank you madam president just want to quickly thank uh huntsville police our engineering
planning and zoning departments and community development for being responsive to some citizen
concerns over the last few weeks thank you thank you sir mr meredith thank you um
i wanted to point out or comment on the fact that we made changes to the minutes of the meeting
in conjunction with the huntsville city school board when you look them up the minutes online
they do not reflect any of the changes made i think that that needs to be changed thank you
for making us aware of that any other comments we will follow up on that make sure those changes
take place council member michelle watkins okay first i want to thank parks and rec had a community
health fair two weeks ago and parks and rec played a big part in getting everything ready for the
health fair at the jocelyn legacy center i also want to thank sarah sarah did an extremely
phenomenal job with bringing together all our community partners so thank you for that sarah
i want to thank scott erwin and community development for always being responsive to
my emails to my request um and you're always so patient and kind and i appreciate that
uh chris mcneese and public works um i bother them a lot too brian walker i appreciate you
and landscape management as well and uh parting out um my family is in town the laniere family
is having their reunion started today we'll go through sunday this is our 50th year celebrating
together as a family so i want to just give my family a shout out and uh welcome them to the
great city of huntsville alabama wonderful um and i will simply conclude by adding my thanks to
those already expressed to the 250th um committee july 4th was incredibly memorable and um just so
grateful to have been able to be there to celebrate the 250th birthday of this great country the parade
ended with a big birthday cake float and it was really quite quite memorable so thank you for that
and then this saturday uh another fun event summer haze this is going to be a program of the south
huntsville main business association it's the inaugural event at the park at haze farm it will
take place this saturday july 11th 10 a.m to 1 p.m there will be activities there will be food trucks
there will be a cooling zone there will be vendors and we just invite everybody come out this is a
rain or shine event so we will look forward to seeing everybody at the park at haze farm it is
one of our newest city parks and this is a great way to inaugurate all fun activities that are going
to be taking place there in the future so we hope everyone will join us there we will move on now to
14a the finance committee report 14a is a resolution authorizing expenditures for payment i move for
authorization and approval of expenditures in the amount of 21 million eight hundred
92 thousand six hundred forty seven dollars and 73 cents second second for mr little motion from
mr maris second from mr little all in favor please indicate aye opposed motion carries 14b is an
ordinance yes there is no report from the finance director miss smith but i do want to remind folks
that there will be a budget work session here in council chambers tomorrow morning at 10 a.m
thank you very much and that will be an input session the budget will not be presented but we
will have input from council members thank you for for providing that announcement 14b is an
ordinance approving appropriations goods or services for district one council improvement funds is there
a motion motion from miss watkins second from mr little miss miss watkins would you like to
share with us yes um everyone knows extracurricular activities are essential to the growth and
development and character of our young people i'm investing this money the city money into a program
out at north woods where we're trying to get the community in and around north woods public housing
involved in recreational sports so this is what this money will be utilized for thank you any
questions for miss watkins comments all in favor please indicate aye opposed motion carries
14c is an ordinance approving appropriations goods or services for district three council
improvement funds chair moves for approval second second from mr little what we're doing here is
we're actually transferring 30 000 from the council improvement funds back into the capital plan to
fleet services and this will be used to help provide funding for a fire truck for the green
mountain volunteer fire association they have raised over 100 000 this will go to supplement
that and then the city will from the fleet services budget make up the difference to get that fire
truck up there it's a very unique fire truck there are some long driveways there's a lot of trees
and this is one that can navigate those really difficult drive those 400 foot driveways to get
water there and then also an allocation to for the summer haze community event again it's inaugural
at a new park just to get people there and to build that sense of community any comments or
questions all in favor please indicate aye can pose the motion carries we have no board appointments
to be voted on we do have several board appointment nominations these will be nominations
only and they will be considered at our next meeting on july 23rd 16a is a nomination to
reappoint david nass to the museum board of the city of huntsville to his current seat for a six
year term to expire august 13 2032 16b is a nomination to reappoint jose griffin to the museum
board of the city of huntsville to her current seat for a six-year term to expire august 13
2032 16c is a nomination to reappoint mark harberger to the huntsville downtown
redevelopment authority group c his current seat for a six-year term to expire july 26 2032 16d
is a nomination to reappoint john burbach to the huntsville downtown redevelopment authority group
c his current seat for a six-year term to expire july 26 2032 and 16e is a nomination to appoint
sharon beauclair to the huntsville downtown redevelopment authority group c to the seat
previously held by joseph clark for a six-year term to expire july 26 2032 again those will be
considered at the july 23 meeting are there any nominations from the floor president mr clink i'd
like to nominate barbara hughes reappointment human relations commission barbara hughes the
human relations commission to her current seat thank you any other nominations all right we will
go on we have no huntsville utilities items we have no legal department items brings us to unfinished
business items for action 19a is an ordinance to amend chapter 15 license and taxes article 3 sales
use rental and lodging tax division 5 lodging tax section 15 of the code of ordinances for the city
of huntsville regarding license fees is there a motion to approve motion for mr little second
by the chair is there's miss smith i know that this item is linked to the tiff 9 which we are
going to be considering in just a little while that is correct um this will this for your
consideration before you this evening is adding a percentage one percent to our lodging tax fees we
currently local locally charge nine percent plus a two dollar service charge that one percent will
be dedicated to the vombrant civic center for repairs maintenance and expansion very good any
questions or comments all in favor please indicate aye motion carries thank you miss smith 19b is an
ordinance amending chapter 2 administration article 4 financial policies division 1 generally
of ordinance 96-864 to add section 2-160 thereby establishing a formal vendor gratuity policy
to provide clear guidance for the authorization and disbursement of gratuity payments
related to the provision of goods and services is there a motion to motion for mr little
second second from miss watkins miss smith yes before you this evening is just an enhancement
to the current policies and rules surrounding gratuity we've been asked by the departments a
number of months ago to come up with some guidelines around that they were there was
confusion on how to do gratuity and specifically when we brought in large meals for different
people so this is providing that guidance we worked closely with the hr department and
administration to craft this and what you see before you now thank you questions or comments
for miss little mr meredith not questions for you i've got some amendments to this
when you're ready to all right would you like to make an amendment yes um it's
son of an english teacher second line um it should read code of ordinances not ordinance
so it needs to be plural not singular um under section c first line no city department employee
or agent shall not promise you need to scratch the knot and then in section d
second line it has shall comma require comma need to strike the commas do you have that in writing for us
sir okay
all right we will include that then are any questions about this amendment
have you the motion has been made to amend with these corrections and they are all um basically
typographical or wording is that correct not really in terms of content correct again son of
an english teacher i will second that thank you all any all in favor of approving this amendment
to uh to this ordinance please indicate by saying aye any opposed then we accepted that
amendment so now we will go back and we will um go back to item 20 i'm sorry 19b
um all in favor of approving this ordinance as amended please indicate by saying aye
aye any opposed the ordinance is then amended and accepted as amended thank you thank you for spotting
those corrections 19c is an ordinance declaring certain equipment surplus to be sold at public
auction there are motion motion for mr little second from the chair all in favor please indicate
aye any opposed the motion carries 19d is an ordinance declaring certain property surplus to
be disposed of per agreement with managed asset recycling solutions llc is there a motion to
approve motion for mr little second from the chair all in favor please indicate aye many
opposed motion carries 19e is an ordinance amending chapter two administration article
eight boards commissions committees and authorities division eight of the code of ordinances of the
city of hunsell alabama to make changes to the city tree commission is there a motion motion
mr little is there a second second from miss watkins and i believe this is just cleaning
up titles and language um does anybody have any questions all in favor please indicate
aye opposed the motion carries 19f is an ordinance amending chapter 27 vegetation article two trees
of the code of ordinances of the city of huntsville alabama is there a motion to approve
second motion from mr merida second from mr cling and again this is simply changing
language from city forester to city arborist all in favor please indicate aye opposed the motion
carries 19g is an ordinance annexing 2.62 acres of land lying on the north side of old monrovia
road east of wane road is there a motion to approve motion for mr little second from mr meredith
do we have any questions for mr newnes
we have a map
mr newnes you want to tell us what we're seeing here absolutely thomas newnes manager of planning
zoning services so thank you council members and mayor battle this item is located north side of
old monrovia road and east of wane road um this is a 2.62 acre parcel that kent has set
right in the middle of our city limits we've been waiting on this procedural action to come through
and it is now petitioning to annex into the city limits so thank you for the consideration any
questions mr merida all in favor please indicate aye any opposed the motion carries thank you
thank you mr newnes that brings us to new business 20 new business items for consideration or action
these items will be approved in one motion unless any member of the council wishes to remove an
item for discussion the reading of each item will be waived unless the council member requests
otherwise are there any items anyone wishes to hold for separate consideration
yes 20g will be held any other items k m y
any other items okay so we have g
okay
okay chair moves for consolidation and approval of items 20a to f 20h to j 20l to x and 20z to 20ac
second by mr little all in favor please indicate aye any opposed the motion carries we will now
move to 20g 20g is a resolution to name create an established tax increment financing district
tiff 9 and to adopt the project plan for tiff 9 is there a motion to approve
move to approve motion for mr little second from mr cling uh mr davis this is long awaited we're
glad to have you here to present this to us good evening council members shane davis director urb
neck don't thank you for the patience uh is a total one today uh what has happened in the last
month shows continued collaboration within this community uh the joint effort with pump city school
school board and this council talking through this mass county commission working through and
passing unanimously and now tonight it's before you uh i have the long-winded presentation pulled up
to go through it if council would like uh just to maybe quickly remind you and the public uh so
these are the projects that you approved tonight we would set uh create this tiff district uh and
tomorrow morning we would send over the legal description of the district boundaries to uh the
tax assessor cliff man and establish the district and that would establish the district for what the
future proceeds of growth that would occur in that district would go into the tiff district to pay
the warrant or the cash if we were to pay for one of these projects with cash not debt
those process annual proceeds would come from the tax assessor's office is any other tiff district
be captured in here just for these projects once these projects have been paid for either through
debt or through just cash the tiff would expire and those new proceeds those new revenues created
in that district would go to the deferred tax recipients uh through through this process so
of the five projects is the von braun center north hall expansion uh north huntsville beltline
greenway uh the the new mill creek park that is part of our choice neighborhood affordable
residential projects in partnership with huntsville housing authority
low avenue improvement improvement and construction of the new huntsville middle school with in
partnership with the huntsville city schools and then renovations for the federal courthouse for
future use of the mass county commission as as they get into their new facilities as they they
work through that process so it's a very balanced project i know from a capital expense the vbc is
a very heavy lift in it but if i think if you look across the board we're addressing different
community needs in this growing community and helping our partners helping the county commission
certainly helping our school system our bond brawn and in that board and also our our housing
authority so i think it's well balanced it's one that we're confident in that
based on the modeling we've put together should pay off early like most of the tips we have brought
you before and i do want to remind that there is a portion of the millage so there's 58 mills if
you live in huntsville uh that you pay there's six and a half mills state we do not capture the
state millage and there's a five and a half mil county-wide educational tax that goes to huntsville
city schools madison county schools and madison city schools that is uh split by population of
student enrollment i believe the state rule is the 15th day of school that is the population count
so that revenue is collected by the mass county tax assessor when they get those numbers they take
that five and a half meals that were that were collected and disperse it to those education
systems we were not capturing that in this till answer any questions you may have questions
mr merida oh mr cling mr merida i'd like to go last because i don't really have questions i just
have a comment okay mr cling okay this is going to be redundant but let's go back to square one
yes is this a tax increase on the public no sir okay can you explain how this money is raised
without it being without it being a tax increase it's not a tax increase i understand that i mean
just for public benefit absolutely people ask about it how does the money where does the money
come from absolutely happy to do so um and thanks for asking so one the city of huntsville you as a
governmental body the city of huntsville has no authority to raise tax uh you have the authority
to go create something and put a referendum for the general public to vote on a new millage
so we're we're set at 58 mills unless there's a vote of the people to raise that that that is
your ability to quote if we're going to raise taxes it's a vote of the people this body also
nor this administration does an assessment on anybody's property that is actually done
by the madison county tax assessor so you have no authority on placing value on anybody's property
so the process that occurs whether you're in a tip district or anywhere else in the city that
process of an individual or business paying annual property taxes you are not in control of that
all the tip district does is capture a boundary of when that assessed value is done by the mass
county tax session as it's done anywhere else in the city or in the county within that boundary
those proceeds from here forward should you vote and create this would go into this district to
pay for these projects once these projects are paid for that district goes away and those proceeds
flow to the entities so it is not a tax increase you are not able to assess somebody higher because
they're in a tiff district you have no authority as a body to do any of that thank you you're welcome
any questions comments my comment is um thank you mr davis i know you put a lot of time in
personal sweat equity into this as you do so many other projects and a lot of folks
hand out or acclimate here and i think you strongly deserve one for your work on this particular tiff
but also so many other urban development projects and economic things that you do to better the city
so thank you sir thanks sir but it doesn't come without the legal department administration
pennie smith her team in finance we we're all a team i'm just hired help i'm just one of many
thank you for recognizing them as well a great a great team doing great work and we should also
recognize that the county commission unanimously approved this plan as well at their meeting last
week we thank them for their support the vbc board has been tireless advocates they have as well and
has been a very active part of this process and we look forward to seeing some really great things
happen as a result of this i was interviewed before the meeting and and council president i
reiterate that this this is an example of collaboration of a good community and how
this community is moving forward because everyone understands the needs they understand the needs of
each other and each other supports i think ron renard said it best in his acceptance of how you
support the school system and vice versa and the madison county commission supporting this body and
you supporting them it's what makes this community different and and i don't think we really appreciate
how unique that collab that genuine people talk about collaboration all the time but to see it
really happen here it motions hard sometimes and and to see it happen here over and over and over
again with these projects is really quite remarkable so thank you for leading that team and for making
all this happen mayor battle thank you for having the vision to put that forward as well
any other comments all in favor please indicate i mean closed motion carries council members thank
you very much thank you 20k 20k is resolution authorizing the mayor to execute change order
number three to the agreement between the city of huntsville and wiregrass construction company inc
for huntsville northern bypass project number 65-10-rd08 and aldot project number crsa stphv-pe10917
is there a motion to approve motion from mr little second from mr cling mr davis thank you
madam president shane davis director urban economic development this is one of these good change
orders although it's not a lot of money but uh it's in the negative direction okay so change
order number three would decrease the contract amount by 31 thousand 440 dollars so this was for
unneeded storm drain that was in the quantity bid items if you've been to northern bypass you've
seen the target home depot grading they're going to start footing in foundation sometime late august
but if you've driven the northern bypass we're getting really really close most of the curves in
mostly are asphalt really between mount lebanon and toyota motor manufacturing is the the heavy
lift piece that's left but the rest of the road if you drive out in that area it looks pretty much
complete we're still on track to have all lanes of traffic open for the end of the year so as you
understand there's a there's a lot of different funding here there's some grant funds that
congressman strong provided there's some mpo funds there's some city cash
so a lot of funding sources so the reason we're bringing you this change order
midstream as we close out certain sections of those federal aid projects like this the storm
drain we need to close out and identify the final cost of those because we get audited and we do all
the books to send into aldot and federal highway so the storm drain is all finished so we're
working on closing that out and there was some quantities not used so we'll go ahead and process
this deductive change order any comments questions all in favor please indicate aye opposed motion
carries and finally 20 why 20 why is a resolution authorizing mayor dendron who random of understanding
regarding the nib in enforcement support system nes s between the hansel police department and
bureau of alcohol tobacco firearms and explosives is there a motion to approve motion for mr little
second from the chair questions or comments anyone has on this yes i did want someone to come up and
explain what this is chief is going to do that because i know that i'll get an email in the
morning talking about ice good evening may i introduce my name is our administrative services
manager what question can we have you can just tell us what this is yes ma'am i've been is a
acronym that stands for a national integrated ballistic information system or network every
firearm that we take in whether it's evidence or found property we do a test fire we take the uh
take the shell case in and we analyze it and we catalog it so that if it's used in any type of
we can match it to that crime and so nests the agreement nest is an i've been enforcement support
system it's a network set up by the atf for all law enforcement who are participating in it to
in case there's a gun use in a crime in birmingham and if it's the same weapon we can connect those
to a crime occurred in other places is anything in this agreement has anything about ice in it
no ma'am thank you and there's no cost to this is that right that's correct no costs
thank you any other comments all in favor please indicate i opposed motion carries thank you chief
thank you that concludes uh old business we'll move now on to new business one item for introduction
this is for introduction only action on this will be taken at the july 23rd meeting
21a is the introduction of an ordinance concerning a franchise agreement between the city of honsville
alabama and the limestone county water and sewer authority again we will take that up at the july
23rd meeting that concludes our business and now to our second roster public comments this portion
of the meeting
oh i'm sorry did i miss some
okay those were taken off okay it's an old agenda
this portion of the meeting is reserved for persons wishing to address the council on
matters relating to the city business whether or not such items are on the meeting agenda
individuals who wish to speak have signed up previously when called approach the microphone
state your name home address and city of residence each speaker may address the council for three
minutes speakers shall refrain from entering into a dialogue with council members or city staff
and for making comments regarding the good name and character of any individual we only have one
person who has signed up and that is alex kim yon and a subject is public library funding
hi it's me my name is alex kim yon hi again um i reside in district three my address is on file
um last time i was here we were there was a presentation from the library about the
downtown building renovation and i'm not gonna try and undersell that as a very important project
but i did want to come back because i know it's budget season and um reiterate that the people
the actual like hospital people who work at the library system have not had a cost of living
raise in two years our collection budgets are stagnant um and it's impacting how many folks we
can hire and how well we can serve the rest of the people of our county um obviously i don't know
anything about renovating or rebuilding anything that is way above my pay grade but i do know that
as cost of living is going up for everybody i work with um across the board right we all see it gas
food electric water all of it's gone up over the past two years and we're still stuck at the same
salaries we've been and it's difficult i've seen so many of my co-workers leave because they can't
raise their kids they can't um pay their bills um they're full on leaving the state and i don't
think any of us want to see folks who are otherwise committed to serving the county
leaving because we can't afford to stay here um so i really just want to comment on again to please
even if we can't fund this whole renovation project please consider increasing funding enough
so that we can get that cost of living we can stay here we can keep serving um our county and
our communities that we love so much thank you thank you very much miss kimmy on um we have no
other speakers who have signed up is there a motion to adjourn motion from mr cling and mr
little we it is 657 and we are adjourned